what does it take from you to write such
books
okay so that's a problem what I mean is
firstly mentally yeah
in terms of research in terms of how you
structure your day as well
yeah the long books took a lot of work
um
because
I was simultaneously assembling an
enormous amount of material researching
it organizing it
um and putting it together and it's an
organic process in which I kept going
backwards and forwards between uh oh hi
Mike that's really nice to see you by
the way Michael Levin is in the house
huge pleasure to meet you in
yes
um
I was just saying um that writing a very
long book like no matter where things
took an enormous amount out of me
because I was doing both very detailed
work and Broad thinking and joining up
the dots and seeing the bigger picture
which is in a way
um a a an exemplification of my belief
that the two hemispheres weren't paying
very localized detailed focus and the
other paying a much broader sustained
folks need to be working together but I
found your work my I mean nothing very
original in my saying this but to me it
was a real uh Revelation and I'm really
fascinated by what you're doing well
likewise thank you so much
good good and I I do cite your work in
the matter with things
um and it raised some interesting
questions which perhaps I could put to
you um but please I mean very very
simple one have you take the the
experiment you did where you
deliberately
um distorted
the areas of the tadpole that would
create the face of the Frog
and yet the Frog
as it were developed using completely
different Pathways from any that could
have been that could have been as it
were programmed in it so it reacted to
this situation as a new situation
responded intelligently and we know many
many instances of this of single cells
for example but in a complex organism
like that it's particularly fascinating
but of course this is happening all the
time when parts of the brain go missing
and the rest of the brain knows it needs
as it were to recover something that it
senses is not there and another part
gets repurposed have you thoughts about
where these in a way
I hate to use the term because people
get so uppity about it but these sort of
they are morphogenetic
um force field where they are what they
are what they're like where they come
from have you have you been exploring
that
we have um yeah so so we divide this
problem into a couple of different
pieces so what we can do now to a large
extent at least in these model systems
is to directly observe somewhat decode
and and modify you know in some cases at
will in some cases not the pattern
memories that allow this collective
intelligence of these cells to build
particular things so we can literally
see these memories in the way that
people who do neural decoding can sort
of read out the evidence of specific
memories in the nervous system and so on
so so that part we have uh there's I
think an even more kind of profound
component to this which is that this
this and and I think and I'm you know
I'm not just using this metaphorically
I'm quite serious when I say this the
the collective intelligence of of this
of the cell of the groups of cells are
able to deploy considerable
sophistication and competency in
navigating the space of possible shapes
and as you as you just pointed out in
novel circumstances they do not simply
just do the same thing every time the
the pattern memories that we can read
tell them where they need to go in this
space and that's fine but getting there
they are able to deploy some really
amazing um competencies and that's the
part that we're only now beginning to to
get a hold of is is what are the
mechanisms that allow them to do new
things and new circumstances to still
get to the essential goal at the end and
so I view this very much as a
goal-directed phenomenon and it's on us
to figure out what are the competencies
right and how and what are the
mechanisms and we have some you know we
have some data on it but but this is the
big I think the big mystery for the next
few decades
you mentioned their memory which is
something as it were almost by
definition from somewhere in the past
and you you suggested you didn't use the
word but you suggested somehow that
there was a sense of direction of the
whole complex system of the organism in
other words a kind of tea loss yeah but
where is the memory and where is the
Telos what is a memory where is where do
your men see start with the use of
scriptures where do they speak a memory
where do they see that memory so so so
the memory is is encoded in a stable
bioelectric state of all the tissues
it's not just the nervous system it's
all the tissues and it allows the
collective to determine whether so so as
far as we can tell it's kind of like a
very simplistic version of this that
would be a set point in a thermostat in
a homeostatic a homeostatic set point
that basically what allows the system to
do is to compare the current state to
the Target State the target state is
encoded by electrically if the delta or
the error is large enough then stress
goes up but various actions will be
taken to reduce that that Delta and so
whereas everyone's familiar with
individual cells doing this in let's say
metabolic space right to keep
temperature pH you know simple things
the collective is now able to operate in
exactly the same way but in a different
space it navigates this morphe space the
space of possible anatomical
configurations Guided by this electrical
memory which we can literally see and
rewrite so we have a number of examples
where we've altered the memory in this
cells with with no genetic change the
cells are happy enough to build
something else if we change the
information that tells them what they
should be building now that part we sort
of have a handle on mechanistically
quite well now the part that we're just
beginning to to to sort of touch is how
the
um creative problem solving happens
because what we can show quite easily
right and it's exactly what you started
with it we can show quite easily that it
is never a matter of well maybe in some
systems it is but but in the majority of
living systems it is not a matter of
taking the same path through that space
come what may they know how to go around
obstacles and deal with all kinds of
weird you know circumstances and I think
I'll throw it since you know we're here
sort of it's just sharing ideas I'll
I'll throw out a kind of a an
unpublished conjecture that was you know
sort of still working on which is why I
think this they're able to do this and I
I think they're able to do this because
this is what they have to do every
single time I don't think this is a
weird third strange capacity that has to
evolve separately I think I call this I
call this right I call this uh the play
The Hand you're dealt meaning that when
when these beings come into the world
they can't really count on anything they
don't know how many cells they're going
to have because we can take embryos and
cut them into little pieces and they
still do the right thing we they don't
know uh what how many copies of the
genome they're going to have they don't
know what the environment is going to be
like every single act of
self-construction and development is
this on the Fly where are we where is my
border where do I end and the world
begins right what effectors do I have
what senses right they have to they have
to do this on the fly every single time
and I think that's why they're so
plastic because Evolution everything
that wasn't plastic probably couldn't
make it you know it's it's Evolution
makes these um
problem-solving machines it doesn't make
solutions for specific narrow problems
that's my guess right that's obviously
very very controversial but that's
that's my guess
exploring that
like is that is it that controversial
though
uh I think it is well you know I think
it requires uh what well well I mean
okay the the part where the part where
it's quite clear that uh living things
can do incredible uh Feats of problem
solving that they were not directly
evolutionarily prepared for that part I
hope is not controversial because the
data are what they are we just see that
and we know that when you you know just
the latest you know our latest example
when you take skin cells off of a off of
an early frog Emery they reassemble into
this into a xenobot they have a
different life with different behaviors
they just you know with no it requires
no long-term evolutionary adaptation
they just do something completely
different and there are many examples
I was just going to say Barbara and
McClintock you know back in the 80s and
so on was was showing this and it's got
a Nobel Prize for it so we're not really
surprised by that anymore
but we shouldn't we shouldn't basically
no but it's all inspiring I mean yeah
we're not surprised but we're we're all
the more awe-inspired well I am anyway I
find this absolutely amazing yeah the
creatures do this yeah yeah that that
part I I hope is not controversial the
part that I think will be controversial
is my suggestion that Evolution does not
take the past as seriously as we sort of
assume that it does we we tend to you
know standard development is so reliable
that it kind of lulls you into this
false sense of security you see it
happening the same time and you say well
yeah of course of course acorns give
rise to oak trees and and you know frog
eggs make frogs what else could they
possibly do because it's so it's so
reliable but uh I think that uh once you
start to probe as you must if you're
going to assay the sort of cognitive
capacity of any creature you have to
start to probe it with novelty to really
make a claim about that you really start
to discover how much plasticity there is
and the fact that it only does the same
thing in every circumstance in the same
circumstance it actually is capable of
doing many different things and why is
that and so this idea that that's
because it can never count on the past
the the present being exactly like the
past right so you can do all kinds of
crazy things you can add cells remove
cells add the no you know add extra
copies of the genome you could put
physical barriers into things you can do
all this stuff and the cells you can
combine you know cells will combine with
other species of cells so you can make
chimeras you can make
um chimeras with inorganic components
put in electrodes and all this kind of
stuff they do fine with all of it
because it's just another day to them
it's just we are in a new environment
like we always are we never know what to
expect and we have to somehow make a go
of it at every point so that's what I
think is the product of evolution I
think that will be very controversial
yeah and what I particularly love about
that from a philosophical point of view
is that in my new book no matter with
things I'm suggesting that the way in
which we think of things in a an
entirely mechanistic way is a mistake
and I tend to invert
um the Assumption so for example you
used to think that the normal State as
it were the state that needs no
explanation is stasis and that motion is
an aberrant State when something comes
in or gives it a push and this is
Newtonian mechanics but that actually
motion is the norm and stasis if it
could ever be truly completely achieved
would be the limit case of motion and I
have a whole lot of these that in fact
Simplicity is the limit case of
complexity and so on but what you're
really saying here is that apparently
following a road path is not the norm
from which these yes
um extraordinary elaborate and inventive
and creative processes are some sort of
um Divergent you're saying that this is
the norm and the the the the following
of a routine path is just something that
we we happen to have taken as the norm
but is a rather the limit case of
creativity yeah yeah well I I completely
agree I think that is the limit case and
I think that that's what they will do as
a lazy sort of um easiest thing when the
environment is the expected simple
environment but it's by no means but
it's by no means assumed and in fact
many things have to be exactly as you
say you know um your your tongue has
these these these rosettes right very
very kind of finely patterned cells if
if you sever the right if you sever the
lingual nerve over the next couple of
weeks there it completely falls apart
even though the cells are alive nothing
is dead every you know everything's
healthy but that organization completely
falls apart because apparently you need
constant input to you know from this
from this this morphogenetic influence
needs to be constantly working to keep
everything together as cells come and go
molecules come and go right that's that
stasis is a lot of hard work I mean it
requires a lot of hard work yes no
that's lovely yeah
so what do you all Mike what are you
working on next year
oh what are you most excited about and
then also I wanted this to be it's so
hilarious because this is supposed to be
like we all come into a pub and we just
drink some beer we just relax and then
this is like the deepest philosophical
conversation that someone said we're
just moving Humanity forward at a bar
so so anyway oh okay yeah please talk
about what you're up to next year Mike
and I'm letting in Don Hoffman Don the
incredible Dawn ah hey Don good to see
you guys I and Mike wow hello Don hello
so I want to know what each of you are
up to next year if you could briefly
outline that and then just and then I'll
shut my mouth
starting with Mike if you don't mind
sure um wow uh let's see well we have we
have lots of lots of things going on in
our group um we have uh efforts in uh
regenerative biology of course trying to
uh really get better at uh convincing
cells to do what we want them to do
which is to rebuild the complex organs
um and appendages we have uh we have
efforts in in cancer and trying to
reverse the kind of loss of
um that basically you know we we view
cancer as a kind of uh shrinking of the
computational boundary between the the
self and the outside world and so when
cells you know when that boundary
shrinks to the level of single cells
they treat the rest of the body as just
external environment and so we're trying
to re-inflate that and get them back to
thinking about big goals in terms of
building organs and healthy tissues and
things like that so so we have some some
continued efforts we've done this in
frog years for years we're now in human
cells and so so we're trying to
hopefully push that push that along and
we have we have we have also some uh
some efforts in um in Ai and looking at
just taking some of the things we've
learned in in biology uh to build novel
uh novel synthetic intelligences that
are not neuromorphic not built on human
brain architecture but just you know
everything from slime molds to cell
groups and so on
um and of course some of the some of the
consent actual stuff too so so there
will be some stuff coming out one thing
I'm particularly excited about is kind
of this this effort we were just talking
about this with Ian this really really
trying to tell a story of the very
earliest boot up of a uh of a of a
protocognitive agent what are the very
first steps that happen when a new being
enters the enters the world so to speak
so how do you go from from you know the
chemistry of
field of of cells to an embryo or a
robot that's active in the world or
something but like what are the earliest
steps of that so I think we could tell
an interesting story about that so
well Don is here everyone
Don Hoffman Don mute Ian and meet Mike I
know you've met each other before but we
have a donkey here who has the sound
effects so thank you Sam
so don don has a book called the case
against reality the links for all of
this will be in the description
so don please take it away I want to
hear from you please I'm gonna shut my
mouth
but as Ian already told us what he's up
to
I'm an old guy I'm retired I'm I'm I'm
uh you know harrowing my soul to meet
the next World I'm doing I I'm I'm on to
small projects I'm through with very
very very big ones that's me
okay okay
I'm there too
I'm retired as well it's not good
yeah but but I'm still doing some some
some big projects the the thing I'm we
just had with paper accepted just the
last couple days for publication on
uh with minor revisions that we're
finishing up it's it's a paper that is
trying to
to connect Consciousness with physics in
a rigorous fashion so the physicists
have discovered that space and time are
not fundamental
as David Gross the Nobel Prize winner
put it in 2005 space-time is doomed and
he gave reasons why space-time is doomed
and
so the Hunt is on for structures Beyond
space-time and just the last eight years
they found them they've uh in 2014 they
published something called the
amplitudehedron and uh
decorated permutations these are
structures not inside space-time they're
not curled up inside little dimensions
of space-time these are structures
utterly and completely Beyond space-time
and space-time is a trivial projection
of these deeper structures and you get
Quantum field Theory computations uh
becoming much more simple when you let
go of space-time Quantum field
computations become trivial and you see
new symmetries in scattering amplitude
data that you couldn't see inside
space-time so it's really over for space
time and and the Gold Rush is on to find
out what's beyond space-time and they're
finding some some wonderful stuff so
this is all in the last decade that that
uh physics at least high energy physics
you know a lot of there's still a lot of
people doing space-time physics of
course but but the high energy people
um who who are the ones who really need
the better tools they're they're done
with space-time they're beyond it
so
this gave us an opening we said look the
physicists
um say the space time was doomed we've
been saying that from our own points of
view um about Consciousness and they
they give us a structure beyond space
times that they found so I said let's
connect with that if can we take our
mathematical model of conscious agents
and connect with this structure Beyond
space-time so decided to try doing that
and doing that about six months ago and
we we did it we found
um the decorative permutations it turns
out um we discovered that there's a
canonical way to take markovian Dynamics
and project them onto decorated
permutations so that was apparently a
new contribution to the mathematics it
was the one that we needed to make
because our dynamics of conscious agents
is
markovian so so we the paper just got
accepted it shows how to take our
makovian dynamics of conscious agents
project it down into space into
space-time using decorative permutations
um with this new map that we came up
with Wow and as a result we make a new
postulate and then I'll stop and I'll
our postulate is that we propose that a
particle in space-time an elementary
particle like bosons leptons and quarks
those are the current elementary
particles that those are actually
projections of so-called communicating
classes of conscious agents and that
that particular proposal is is precisely
because of this mapping with decorated
permutations it dictates that that has
to be the the correspondence particles
are projections of communicating classes
of markovian Dynamics so so we're now
working on the follow-up paper now is to
get momentum Mass spin all these things
come porting down from the theory of
conscious agents into space-time and
predicting specific scattering
amplitudes with specific dynamics of
conscious agents so it's it's conscious
imperialism we want to show that all of
physics starts is just a projection in
fact not just a projection it's an
artifact of the projection of
Consciousness even our perception of
particles is an artifact of projection
not an insight into the deep properties
of reality so that's that's that's
that's fun
wow
what would you say it's very impressive
what you say Don and I I don't um I
haven't the advantage of having been
able to research what you're researching
and I may might well not understand it
if I tried but what would you say
to the idea that this looks like a
process whereby everything of reality is
stripped away and this is of course your
title
um
and this leaves the ordinary person
philosopher physicist or simply
um the everyday guy on the Clapping
orbit with a problem which is that
something is must be considered more
real than others and there must be
something that our Consciousness has
some awareness of other than purely
itself this process seems like one in
which you have done what Burton Russell
said mathematics and physics did which
was simply to strip all the reality from
the world from the cosmos and produce a
very thin texture of equations and
numbers now if you do that then you go
oh goodness realities disappeared I I
find this a little bit worrying because
I don't know how you can even say
anything
in English rather than just an equation
without involving space and time
at space and time of the fundamental
ways in which we structure everything we
think and so yes of course you can
invent an abstract platonic realm in
which everything's been disappeared by
some clever Mass but I suspect this is
not getting closer to a truth but
further and further away from it I'm a
follower of Leeds Mullins who says I
mean he's a great physicist it can't be
dismissed who thinks there is nothing
more real than time and as we start
dismissing time you've you've lost the
plot basically
right right so so those are of course
very very natural objections to raise
um and so I would respond in two
different directions one is that um
for the physicists who are doing this
right they what they're finding is that
it's space time that is full of
unrealities
for example the the
the ghostly particles that that you get
from confinement diagrams so you these
virtual particles that that are created
and annihilated and you have to add them
all up to get these scattering
amplitudes it turns out that they're not
needed and and that they're just a
distraction when you let go of them then
hundreds of pages of algebra turns into
three terms that you can compute by hand
and you get the right scattering
amplitudes so so space time is actually
hiding the truth it's not showing you
the truth it's actually and and the
ghost particles that you know we get the
final diagrams are are literally just
nonsense and not needed so when you get
rid of them and then you're finding new
symmetries that are true so you're
finding that something called the
infinite yanging symmetry is actually
true of our observations that the
colliders and you cannot see that
directly in space-time it can't be
represented in space-time
so on the physics side what they're
finding is letting go of space-time is
actually getting them closer to some
quote unquote truth not further and and
they're finding out what parts of
space-time are irrelevant that but from
a now from a phenomenological
perspective and a psychological
perspective
um our theory of conscious agents
um takes conscious experiences at
firsthand it says conscious experiences
are real a headache is a real experience
all right you just watched a clip from
an eight-hour live stream Behemoth
Leviathan podcast from theories of
everything which is a channel where we
explore physics mathematics and
Consciousness what is the Theory of
Everything how do you merge Quantum
field Theory with General relativities
click here or in the description for the
full podcast where there are several
people make appearances all the way from
George Knapp to Jeremy Corbell to Gary
Nolan to Avi Loeb to John verakee to
Donald Hoffman to Michael Levin to Ian
mcgilchrist and 40 more all in one eight
hour long podcast links in the
description